now the demons their number one job is
to get you to sin
when most people talk about demons they
think of The Exorcist movie
um the Devil with the horns and the
spear
um he can appear that way but 90
six seven percent of his work is to
tempt to sin and all of his minions
because when we sin we break away from
God and once we break away from God then
they can really go after us like it's
like stepping is a Pit Bull with a five
foot chain it's like stepping in to the
three foot Mark you're suddenly now in
the zone right then they can really
attack you so if they can get you to sin
then they can really have a field day
and really ruin your life